[Singing, praying in native language and drumming.]
[Jewel James:] We're up here in the Mount
Baker Snoqualmie United States Forest and...
...behind me is an old growth western red
cedar.
At one time the cedars went all the way to
the shoreline and ...
...were a couple thousand years old.
The trees were so thick, you couldn't walk
through the forest, the old growth.
Most of the forest has been logged, and so
there's quite a few old growth cedars yet,
but they're hard to come by...
...and so we worked with the US Forest Service
here, and there's one tree that fell from
this spot.
It got undermined by all the wind and the
rain and the snow, and it finally fell.
But this tree behind me is also going to fall,
and it's undermined.
About sixty percent of its root wad is exposed
to the elements, and so when we talked to
the Forest Service...
...they said we could have this log for the
National Library of Medicine project, as well.
And so we're really fortunate to have some
elders from the Lumbee nation and some trained
traditional young persons...
...from the Navajo nation that have come here
to help us pray for this.
This tree here.
The one that's already down.
[Singing and drumming.]
[Elder:] We come here today to pay honor.
This man that's going to take you home, not
to take your life...
...but to give you new life, to transform
you, that you'll bring home peace to our people
throughout the nation.
[Singing and drumming.]
[Jewel James:] When we come and take a tree
out of the forest, we're supposed to be appreciative.
We're supposed to be respectful, and we're
supposed to humbly ask permission to take
this tree...
...because the forest is full of medicine,
and the cedar tree is just one more of the
medicine people.
This totem pole is for the National Library
of Medicine, and the story is about protection
and preservation...
...of traditional knowledge and traditional
medicine.
Totem poles are about symbols and the symbols...
...usually tied us -- stories, legends, myth,
folklore it ties to some of the traditional
knowledge within...
...a native community.
They all have their stories about their relationship
with the earth.
And in that relationship over time, they learned
about medicine.
We're pretty excited about participating with
the National Library of Medicine.
We know that they have a national library
as well as regional, branches of the National
Library and...
...they also make themselves available and
participate with local universities on different
projects and programs.
And so as a native community, we know that
we have culture, and we know that we have
traditional knowledge.
We know that we have knowledge handed down
from generation to generation about traditional
medicine...
...but we don't know how to protect it.
Most of the time, we've learned over the centuries
to keep it quiet.
And so we're hoping that the journey as we
go to the various native communities will
create awareness...
...you know, and that we'll come to understand
that the National Library of Medicine is a
resource...
...that it has information that we can access,
utilize, also, that it's not a one-way relationship.
It's not them coming to usů
...and asking to document and catalogue everything
we know.
It's them coming to us and saying this is
what we know.
You know, you're welcome to it.
I think it's a good public institution that
has a basic open door and is transparent.
[Flute playing.]
[Narrator:] For native peoples, healing is
more than the treatment of physical symptoms.
You see, native healing is intertwined with
larger concepts, such as self-respect, spiritual
balance...
...family, and a connection with the land.
That's why for native peoples individual healing
cannot be separated from...
...community wellness; they're one and the
same.
In this exhibition we explore these native
concepts of...
...health and wellness.
Honoring the native tradition of oral history
we'll gather the chorus of healing voices...
... from across the country so that you may
hear their stories in their own words.
[Flute playing.]
[Narrator:] A reverence for nature is common
among all native peoples.
Unlike modern society which erects barriers...
...between itself and the natural world, native
cultures derive strength and healing from
the land and water.
Individual wellness cannot be achieved when
the connection to nature is missing or contaminated.
You'll hear personal stories about the importance
of land, water, the environment, and the medicinal
plants...
...that have been a source of healing for
millennia.
So this is [in Hawaiian language].
This is [in Hawaiian], and this is the [in
Hawaiian] of the green tea leaf.
This is for a broken bone.
[Narrator:] Native peoples believe that each
person has a responsibility for his or her
proper behavior and health.
These stories offer ideas about personal responsibility,
family and tribal ties, role models, and identity.
[Katherine Gottlieb:] Our native men are still
leaders in our communities.
In days of old, they would stand and protect
their families.
They would die for their women and their children
and what we're saying is do that again.
Come back and do it today, and this time do
it around domestic violence, child sexual
abuse, and child neglect.
End that for us as strong men and warriors
just like they did in the days when they had
to stand up and fight for us.
We want them to do it today.
[Narrator:] The gathering of the community
is a cherished practice because in a traditional
society the community...
...is a source of support and healing.
For native peoples' individual health cannot
be separated from...
...community wellness.
You'll hear about the differences between
life on the reservation and life in the city...
...and attitudes that native people share
regardless of where they're living.
[Ralph Forquera:] The displacement of native
people to cities has had a profound effect
on just their psyche, how they see the world...
...how they view the world, their ability
to trust people, their ability to interact
in a way that allows us to be able to...
...instill in them a sense of belonging, a
sense of wellbeing that can translate into
better health.
[Narrator:] Native peoples live in two worlds,
one that honors the way of their ancestors
and one that acknowledges...
...the conveniences and challenges of modern
society.
Wellness is sought through the preservation...
...of languages, ceremonies, and burial practices,
reverence for the creator, and respect for
the wisdom...
...of elders are important traditions that
have survived for millennia.
You'll also hear stories of loyalty and...
...military service that exemplify modern
native traditions of service and patriotism.
[Thomas Begay:] It was 0900 when we hit the
beach.
We maintained communication under all kinds
of fire, snipers...
...you name it.
The officer or somebody writes the message.
All we do -- it's an endless stream of messages...
...and all we do is transmit into Navajo.
In Navajo there would be another talker.
We sent close to 800 in four to eight hours
-- came out perfect.
[Narrator:] Taken together these concepts
influence a native person's approach to good
health and inform their decisionů
ů whether to pursue Western medicine or traditional
healing practices when confronted with an
illness.
[Senator Inouye:] Well, I'm glad we're beginning
to recognize officially the worth of these
native doctors.
And I'm glad we're doing this in Native American
-- the Indians, also.
The Congress of the United States is considering
native sovereignty measures, which would give
them...
...federal government recognition as we give
to Indians.
Once that is set up, I think one of the high
priorities...
...would be to set up a native hospital to
revive the practice of native medicine, for
example.
I think that's a good thing.
[Flute music playing.]